tonight democrats dereliction of duty on
the issue of violent crime is as
undeniable as ever it's just disgraceful
it's diabolical and it is destroying our
great american cities people aren't safe
and secure there's no law and order
today at st patrick's cathedral the
beautiful st patrick's cathedral in new
york city now with thousands upon
thousands of officers from all across
the world in attendance i mean a mile
miles and miles of heroes showed up for
this funeral that was being held for
fallen nypd hero jason rivera he was
shot and killed by the way execution
style on the end one week ago while
responding to a domestic call in harlem
his partner was also killed according to
reports the deranged killer a career
criminal quote kept firing at the
wounded cops even as they lay helplessly
on the floor a complete execution
unfortunately it is a tragedy that has
become all too common all across the
country as far left leaders refused to
take the issue of crime seriously they
refused to respect police officers and
put the interests of violent criminals
over the interests of law-abiding
citizens
and don't forget it was far left new
york city district attorney alvin bragg
he's the guy that announced during his
first few days in office that he would
be coddling all criminals and applying
less stringent policies for prosecuting
a whole host of different crimes and
today in an act of bravery the widow of
fallen officer rivera dominique his wife
spoke out on the lawlessness plaguing
the city the relentless disgusting
denomination or demonization of law
enforcement the recklessness of alvin
bragg as she indicated by the way this
system is failing all of us powerful
words listen
friday morning began just like every
other morning before work
you were always my big spoon
watching netflix
youtube law enforcement shorts
read me your emails
and wait for your mom to come home
you packed your book bag
because we had to leave before too
and really
before too sharp
because of your ico sergeant
you would drive me home
and say goodbye with three kisses all
the time
and texting me when you were 84.
that was our routine
later that day i received the call i
wish none of you
that are sitting here with me will ever
receive
i had gotten a notification from the
citizen app
which was my central
and i saw
that two police officers were shot in
harlem
my heart dropped
i immediately texted you and asked you
are you okay
please tell me you're okay
we used to share locations
and find my iphone and when i check
yours i see that you're a harlem
hospital
i thought maybe you were sitting on a
perp
but still
nothing then i get a call asking if i'm
jason's wife
and then i had to rush to the hospital
walking all those steps seeing everybody
staring at me was the scariest moment
i've
experienced
nobody was telling me anything
thousands of people were surrounding me
and yet i fell alone
i couldn't believe you left me
and jason is so happy right now that all
of you are here
through pain and sorrow this is exactly
how he would have wanted to be
remembered
like a true hero
or like i used to call him big pio
rivera
you have the whole nation on gridlock
and although you won't be here anymore
i want you to live through me
the system continues to fail us
we are not safe
anymore not even the members of the
service
i know you were tired of these laws
especially the ones from the new d.a
i hope he's watching you speak through
me right now
i'm sure all of our blue family is tired
too
but i promise
we promise
that your death won't be in vain
i love you to the end of time
we'll take the watch from here
[Applause]
our prayers are with these two officers
their families their loved ones and i'm
going to ask again tonight for what
feels like what the millionth time
how many more of these stories are we
going to have to cover
before far left democrats start taking
the issue of law and order and safety
and security to pursue happiness
seriously you know by the way where's
black lives matter i didn't hear from
aoc or nancy pelosi either black lives
matter they claim to care about the
welfare of our most vulnerable
communities
remember the blm chapter recently
complaining that murdered police
officers they're treated like heroes
this was a minority officer just so
happens in this case why didn't joe
biden kamala harris too busy to attend
the funeral today where's barack obama
michelle obama pelosi aoc where's the
congressional committee to investigate
not only these murders the 574 riots in
the summer of 2020. why didn't they call
up the troops on january
6 when they had as required by law the
the signature of the president to sign
off of the president all of this has got
to stop the nypd is a minority majority
police force like many big cities
why don't their lives seem to matter to
democrats as much
why is there not an outcry over this
because the way democrats have
surrendered our cities they have
surrendered it they have created a lot
of this lawlessness and all of it is
unconscionable crime is surging
everywhere records all over the country
in 2021 and that's on top of a bad year
2020. quality of life is decreasing
the fbi according to them international
police killings has now reached a
20-year high
346 officers shot in the line of duty in
2021 alone yeah that's another
multi-year high ambush style attacks
against cops up 115 percent over the
previous year and it's not just new york
this is city after city the same story
blue states you know run by liberal
democrats for decades look out in los
angeles a 26-year-old transgender child
molester was only given two years in a
juvenile facility
after pleading guilty to sexually
assaulting a ten-year-old girl
now the judge criticized far left d.a
george gascon whose office declined to
prosecute the repeat offender as an
adult tying the hands of the judge
despite the crime happening two weeks
before he turned 18 and get this this
convicted molester will not even have to
register as a sex offender want a moving
in next door to you in reality the
defund dismantle nobel movement is
responsible for all of this insanity and
all of this violence all of this is
preventable and police all across the
country they all have a target on their
back now we've shown you the deadly
tragedies night after night it is a
direct result of far left radicalism and
not respecting the rule of law not
respecting law enforcement always
sweeping with a broad brush yeah one
percent of officers are conceived are
bad apples but instead of protecting
peaceful law-abiding americans well what
happens democratic-run cities they just
cut and run provide cover for criminals
so they can get out and do it again hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else